no matter how fast you run no matter how  far you go the Beast will follow man  cannot escape his fate Hercules  your name  the rally cry  we all know your legend you're the son  of Zeus only want to be a husband and a  father  you cannot deny what you are the gods  will punish you for it the gods that  kills your family have unleashed hell on  earth  the descendants of Hades they cannot be  killed by an ordinary mortal the people  need you I have no hero with a course  can be stronger than a god take revenge  for your families save these people  and restore order to this world  do we die in this battle  like time duck come yet I'm not sure  about yours  we will fight for you  make yourself  now tell me  ah